s'il vous plaît
maintenant dans la boulangerie là
moutarde
[Musique]
du ketchup
moutarde
personne n'a vu il est tombé par terre
je vais bien ici regarder la sortie de
métro
mais tu te mets pas le nom de ma
boutique c'est pas ta boutique y a pas
marqué ton nom
allez merguez
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire fuir les
clients c'est ça
allez allez on en profite on en profite
pendant que
moi aussi je vais te la mouiller ta
merguez
qu'est-ce que tu fais
ça va beaucoup moins bien marché
maintenant je te le renverse partout
tout seul
je suis désolé voilà vous m'enverrez
votre note de teinturier
partout laissez-moi tranquille
regarde-moi ça le boulot qui fait non
non
s'il vous plaît
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
pourquoi faire
[Applaudissements]
chez toi oh ouais on joue pas avec la
nourriture
tapis et tu veux quoi aussi tu veux quoi
dis-moi
allez vite j'ai faim
[Musique]
et en plus tu dis que mes pites elles
sont pas bonnes
je sais pas un petit truc pas vrai
peut-être tout est frais ici
[Musique]
ça va c'est bon
ça va
bon je vais continuer tranquille
[Musique]
où est-ce qu'on est par contre
j'y crois pas
[Musique]
3 2 1 et bien oui Julien je suis
actuellement dans la grande roue ou les
gens se sont mobilisés puisque
trois quatre et bien oui Julien je suis
actuellement dans la troc
souhaitez-vous que la grande route
pour que la grande roue reste sur la
oui ce mobiliser par différents moyens
éventuellement oui j'ai pas la porte
pourquoi malheureusement
respirer monsieur
alors après son départ du site
pensez-vous seriez-vous favorable va
dans oh là là trois quatre après son
départ du site
je suis désolé
ça va
vous rentrez chez moi
et bien merci
je voudrais une glace une double à la
vanille s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
double double
[Musique]
encore un peu ça va
voilà ça fait 10 €
euros
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
ça va
[Applaudissements]
oui ça va
quoi
[Applaudissements]
ça va
alors tout le monde s'en branle alors
attention derrière excusez-moi alors on
va vous faire rentrer couple par couple
s'il vous plaît
on a eu des problèmes à la semaine
dernière
[Musique]
[Rires]
un petit 85 bonnet
détecteur de gros nichons c'est pour ça
oh là là il y a du monde là oh là là
au niveau du pubis
malheureusement vous avez quoi là c'est
la ceinture de chasteté c'est ça
vous avez pas laissé la clé dans la
voiture j'espère parce que ce soir
peut-être que
bonne journée madame
que personne ne vous voit quand même
un peu comme tout le monde tiens la
manquerait c'est là que ça sonne
[Musique]
dans le ballon allez-y
j'ai pris une coupe de champagne
[Musique]
parce que plus les gens boivent dehors
moins ils boivent à l'intérieur et moi
ça nous fait de l'argent vous voyez
que c'est bien
c'est merveilleux
une histoire pour m'endormir
basque alors il y a un vieux mécréant
la porte basque dimanche je viens à la
maison
je suis bien là-bas tu me laisses faire
un peu alors le lendemain
il y a deux réponses une bonne et le
mauvaise la bonne vécu alors sois
tranquille dit au Paradis on joue à la
porte basque la mauvaise tu commences à
jouer demain
[Musique]
vous êtes bien là ça va me faire de
l'air un peu problème
[Musique]
ça y est on est réveillé vous faites
trop de bruit
je vous envoie
[Applaudissements]
c'est dur
ça dépend des fois
où
on m'a dit les frites c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
de temps en temps
j'y crois pas
c'est bon la troisième encore une
incroyable
[Applaudissements]
les frites maintenant
[Musique]
chez ma femme elle est en vacances c'est
peut-être pour ça aussi
tu es rentré à moi
et puis bonne pêche
ah je rigolais tout à l'heure quand j'ai
dû mettre une frite sur l'accent j'y
attends après je rigolais plus quand je
l'ai vu sortir la truite j'ai plus
rigoler tiens ça y est c'est parti
en dessous c'est pas vrai
elle est pas accroché là c'est très gros
là parce que c'est mais c'est très gros
c'est peut-être une très grosse truite
je vais la sortir là je vais le lancer
je mange pas
c'est quoi ça
[Rires]
[Musique]
regardez ça comme ça
non mais je vois pas qui c'est qui
en scooter
vous assistez pas c'est tout ce que je
peux vous demander si c'était moi
j'arrive de bosser donc vous insistez
pas c'est pas moi
votre patron vous vous demandez votre
adresse
attention c'est chaud attention oh là là
oh non regardez ce que vous avez fait je
vais les revendre je vais les revendre
c'est pas grave
tu as goûtez-moi ça madame goûter moi ça
goûter moi ça goûter moi ça
Goûter Goûter
alors comment elles sont j'ai rien
demandé j'ai dit comme ça je veux que ça
à faire emmerder le monde
si vous avez commandé des tripes je le
mets dans la boîte aux lettres
tu t'envoies ça change tout de suite
dans la gueule toi quoi j'entends pas
je les mets dans la boîte aux lettres
ok ok
[Applaudissements]
allez au revoir
[Musique]